ja ich bin froh einfach dass ich noch
überhaupt da sein darf und leben und ich
dass nein ich das hier gemacht nicht
ehrenrunde drehen hat das ist wenn die
brustmuskeln die das machen ja es wird
die hand auf einer herdplatte legen und
ich kann sie nicht wechseln ja der kopf
denkt halt dass die hand noch das spiel
wirklich meine finger und andere wege
steht die schuldfrage noch im raum oder
denkt ihr darüber gar nicht mehr nach
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
eine neue folge kimi
wir machen einen objekt orte und zwei
nannys movie nobert ich habe das
letztens im supermarkt gesehen dachte
ich mache jetzt einfach nach aber nicht
alleine heute habe ich den ganz
besonderen gast bei mir und zwei die
liebe china hallo schön dass du da bist
ich freue mich das besondere bei dir ist
vielleicht kannst du dich auch gleich
selber mal vorstellen aber ich glaube
man sieht zeit direkt schon bei dir du
hast eine armprothese und das ist auch
der grund warum ich dich ein bisschen
entdeckt habe und wir gehen und später
noch einmal darauf ein was ich so
besonders an gina finde und vielleicht
erzählst du erst mal woher kommst du die
alt bist du was machst du beruflich und
wie ist das passiert also ich bin ja ich
bin 21 jahre alt kommen aus wuppertal
und ja ich habe eine ausbildung macht
studieren aber jetzt schmerz bedingt
gegen das halt nicht mehr
und ja hatte motorradunfall vor
eineinhalb jahren ok vor anderthalb
jahren okay was ist genau passiert
kannst es vielleicht auch noch mal so
für die zuschauer erklären also ich bin
mit meinem freund richtung radevormwald
gefahren und wir wollten eigentlich ein
kaffeetrinken fahren und mein freund hat
dass wir sehr offen wir haben geredet
in einer linkskurve und sind
weggerutscht also wissen noch nicht
warum es war nicht die geschwindigkeit
schuld dass wurde bestätigt es war halt
ein fahrfehler es kann halt vieles sein
oder sie handeln was gelegen haben
verbremst ich kann mich bewegt habe er
kann sich bewegen haben und dann bin ich
über die straße gespielt hat und wenn
dann so einen abhang runter und bin dann
gegen den baum geflogen wobei dann der
arme abgerissen ist okay das heißt wenn
ich jetzt so direkt fragen darf das
heißt dein arm war direkt ab und erlag
war sie neben euch oder oder ist das
erste krankenhaus dann alle zweifel
sucht totaloperation das heißt der arm
ist innerlich abgerissen also die nerven
und gefäße sind abbau äußerlich ist noch
dran an der haut und aber meine freundin
hat ihn schon nicht mehr in der
motorradjacke gespürt die meint das war
das total weich irgendwie wollten halt
nichts sagen und mich nicht zu
beunruhigen
und mein becken war noch beidseitig
gebrochen mein rechter unterschenkel
zertrümmert das war halt von oben ist
und eine komplett baustellen so und der
wurde erst zwei wochen später amputieren
also ich war zwei wochen auf der
intensivstation erst danach wurde der
amputiert weil er halt versucht
produzierten ja klar und warst du immer
wach was du immer da oder lachs du auch
im koma ich lag zwei tage im koma was
ich wurde nie copter in haiti geflogen
und zählt und notoperiert
und dann wurde ich zwei tage ins koma
gelegt und als du aufgewacht bist was du
es dir durch den kopf geschossen
erinnerst du dich daran habe ich auch an
alles was beim unfall war also während
des fluges sage ich mal von mir schon
als sich vom motorrad runter bin mann
hat in der kurzen zeit tausend gedanken
also das ist wirklich krass buchmann
nach singen ich habe arbeit letztes an
mich gedacht so was mit mir ist es waren
erst mal alle anderen sachen bevor ich
dann kam das war im krankenhaus also für
mich war das alles erst mal sucht ja ich
konnte das alles nicht glauben kann hat
meinem aufgefallen denn höhere gewalt
war halt mega schwer mich war erstmal
was das material und merkt keiner sagen
alle ja alles gut mach dir keine sorgen
und ich dachte okay es ist komisch so
warum sagen die mir nicht recht was man
kann ich nicht mit ihm reden der hat ein
schädel hirn traum und er war halt noch
sehr
leider musste erstmal selber klarkommen
was da passiert ist wer war noch in
verschiedenen krankenhäusern
ich habe nämlich geguckt ist er neben
mir geht man ja von außen zu einem fall
hat war aber halt nicht wahr dann auch
für mich komisch wenn ich nachts um das
schießen einen schlimmsten gedanken
durch den kopf weil du denkst gleich
dass er aus einer damit wir dich schon
sagen die vielleicht nicht was passiert
ist dein freund geht es körperlich gut
ja der hat keine bleibenden schäden von
unserer fraktion hält so ein paar
berichte und so war es aber alles
reparabel sachen sag ich und das ist
auch gut für mich weil wenn er noch was
gehabt hätte ich kann schlecht damit
umgehen wenn es anderen verschlingen und
es wäre noch mal eine belastung gewesen
wenn man das so hört das ist schon das
sitzt jetzt schon gerade voll tief in
meinen knochen wenn ich mir so anhören
du kannst aber darüber reden also ist
gerade mal eineinhalb jahre her war das
schon immer so von anfang an oder
brauchst du da auch ein paar monate zeit
für also wenn der unfall passiert wird
die direkte psychologin gestellten weil
die halt sagen ich meine das symbol die
traumautos so viele sachen gehabe kann
sich erinnern und dann hast du heute
psychologe und ich hab im ersten moment
das war direkt auf der intensive
stimmung merkt du kannst gut drüber
reden und mich war es so ich hatte so
einen abstand dazu also ich mir war klar
was da passiert ist und ich ist es auch
es ist schlimm aber ich konnte es
erzählen weil ich halt die ganze zeit
dachte okay du hast überlebt so um du
lebst noch kleiner satz dachte mir warum
ich warum ist das jetzt passiert aber
irgendwann nach kam dieses hey du hast
das überlebt ich habe in der ersten sieg
habe nicht eine sekunde daran gedacht
dass irgendwie jan schulz hat die
psychologin auch gesagt so dass es halt
kraft stark ich habe mich selber drauf
gesetzt endlich gezwungen
für mich stand darf nicht im raum ich
habe gesagt warum uns das jetzt noch
schwärmen ich brauche ihn also ist das
eher kontraproduktiv werde ich dann
sagst du du du wohnt ihr zusammen ja und
da habt ihr auch da schon zusammen
gewohnt oder war das ist später
entscheidung also er war eigentlich
immer bei locken
das war schon früh so dass wir dann
immer zusammen waren aber halt seit dem
unfall ist jetzt eigentlich immer dabei
ich brauche hilfe ich solche sachen halt
nicht hin und da bin ich dann zu wenn er
das
das hat für mich auch mal da gehen wir
auch gleich noch mal näher darauf ein
was hat sich verändert werde umfallen
was es so alltäglich ist was du jetzt
vielleicht nicht kannst also merken in
diesem video ist das rezept wirklich
eher nebensache und deswegen schreibe
ich euch dann auch die die ganz genauen
schritte unten infobox auf was sonst
nicht mache aber ich finde ich super
spannend dass du hier bist und ich hab
so verdammt viele fragen und du meinst
doch ich darf dir alle fragen stellen
wie super offen
ich würde sagen wir starten jetzt so
langsam mit ihrem boden und dann später
vielleicht doch noch mal ein bisschen
naja das ist jetzt zerlassene butter
hier habe ich kekse dritten teil aus
butterkeksen und verkauf keksen und
jetzt kannst du ja einmal umrühren
gerade hier so mitten drin sind ist das
denn im alltag klar natürlich machst du
abstriche im alltag was ist das größte
manko was vor dem unfall noch ganz
normal ging haare machen also die haare
wirklich hoch binden zum zopf dicht zu
machen und halt kochen also wenn ich
irgendwas schelewas so kartoffeln zu
schälen
ein mega schwer ich habe zwar meine
hilfreichen so aber trotzdem
es dauert auch gar nicht länger dauern
sagt topf machen ich habe aber auch
instagram gesehen auch dann am col trick
ja bis dahin
da kann ich mir halt alle machen der
halter tief weit unten ist werde ich
mich halt an den hebel dran machen wir
das gemüt und dania führen wir nicht
mehr so dass fest und gibt es da so
tutorials wurde das abkommen so den
eigenen ideen kreativ also vieles wird
mir auch geschickt und sagen hey guck
mal das kanzlerin so machen
hier hab ich bin auch vieles sucht noch
selber aus weil ich war schon vor dem
unfall sehr lösungsorientiert also wenn
das nicht geklappt hat die letzte die
eigentlich zu anderen leuten hingeht und
frack spiel ist eigentlich immer selber
alles jetzt den wohn einfach flach
andrücken und hatte ich das schon also
das hätte ich mit sicherheit mehr
zusammengeschweißt oder dich und jan
besser gesagt was mich so interessieren
würde steht die schuldfrage noch im raum
oder denkt ihr darüber gar nicht mehr
nach ja sich merck schon bei ihm das ist
ein thema ist gerade wenn ich schmerzen
habe auch dass er dann halt schon
jain macht schon fertig so wenn ich ihm
gesagt ja mein arm tut mir weh und so
was ich sag mal so einen großen und
ganzen ist jetzt der unfall ist kein
streitthema so wir fangen jetzt nicht an
sich zu streiten wegen des unfalls klar
kommt manchmal die situation
ich krieg war es nicht hin und er sagt
ja warum schreibst du hast wenn jetzt
nicht warum kriegt das nicht hin und
dann sage ich ja warum wohl
klar ist vor mir das halt unfair wenn
ich dann sagt ja wegen dem ist es wohl
so ich meine dass es gehört sich nicht
so weil er schon genug damit zu kämpfen
aber da muss man halt auch meine seite
stehen wenn jemand wie gesagt ja was
brauchst jetzt so lange da war kriegst
du das nicht hin dass ich dann pampig
reagiert aber das ding ist das ist
eigentlich stellt immer geklärt also wir
das ist nie lange ein thema welche ich
merke so okay das war unangebracht und
weißt du ich sag dann auch hey das war
blöd von mir so und dann ist es auch
wieder gut am ende des tages bist du
auch nur ein mensch und jeder hat auch
wenn nicht der arm ab ist was die
situation wo nun mal das kenne ich auch
mit haben sie da reagiere ich mal patzig
und niesen mit hsv war vielleicht auch
nicht so das ist ja ganz normal das ist
schon super angedrückt den links kurz
zur seite und dann machen wir es eben
die creme und zwar gehen dafür einmal
vorüber zum herd und kochen milch mit
agar agar auf das ist halt so eine
alternative zwischen latin und das
kannst du ja auch übernehmen das heißt
du kannst du den einen arm voll
funktionsfähig
aber ich sehe auch du nimmst den anderen
immer selber hoch ist die steuer ist es
gar nicht so seine gedanken also
eigentlich könnte ich ihnen ja benutzen
nicht steuer jährlich die
brustmuskulatur aber ich beherrsche das
noch nicht so gut dadurch dass ich halt
auch die ganze zeit phantomschmerzen
habe kann ich nicht so richtig üben weil
je mehr phantomschmerzen wenn ich über
sind die phantomschmerzen extrem hab was
war das holz phantomschmerzen
phantomschmerzen heißt es fühlt sich
anders wird die hand auf einer
herdplatte legen ich kann sie nicht
wechseln also die legen kann ich spüre
die hand auch hier die hand ist hier
unten also diese schmerzt es nicht am
ende des stückes sondern wirklich in der
hand drin und manchmal ist es ein gefühl
wie beim unfalls wird die hand zu über
den ausfall schlittern und der kopf
denkt halt dass die hand noch da ist
für wirklich meine finger und an dass
der sänger auf merck auch wenn das
wetter schlechter wird und im winter ist
halt extrem mit den schmerz im sommer
ist es besser aber im winter ist es halt
so ein höhepunkt ja ich habe es
eigentlich immer so seit dem unfall
eigentlich jeden tag und die stärker
durch darauf fokussiert desto mehr stört
die haare scheint aber dass der gerade
auch gesagt du hast nicht dran gewöhnen
dass ich ja auch wieder stark finde weil
in österreich vorstellen deswegen habe
ich auch so ein respekt vor dir wenn ihr
euch mal so auf social media der gina
anguckt die du bist manchmal happy als
so manch einer denkt gar keine sorgen
hat sag ich meine das ist das hat mich
so beeindruckt deswegen werde ich auch
umso dankbarer dass du platt ihr willst
so wir machen jetzt mit unserer creme
weiter das heißt du kannst rühren und
ich geb dir hier in die milch noch
zucker und agger rein und kochen wir das
auf und dann ist wichtig dass das zwei
minuten dann ständig rühren ja und jetzt
kommt einfach nochmal frischkäse dazu
dann kannst du schön kräftig rühren
kommt nochmal ne ne extrakt rein und
dann lässt man das ganze ein bisschen
abkühlen
besser sind als problem da geht es schon
los da meine ich das wie willst du das
alleine dann machen
dies allein mache dann kannst du gar
nicht nur das schiebt sich hin und her
weil die fläche auch so glatt und zu den
raum zwischen den griff ach so ja gleich
besser ist ihm festhalten
ich kann's versuch mit gar nicht dass
nein das ist ja welche man nicht
ehrenrunde drehen war
das ist eine brustmuskeln die das machen
ja so oder rechte und kann sich
wenigstens sich die hände verbrennen
das ist der vorteil und apropos prothese
ich glaube also was mich interessieren
bestimmt auch die liebe zu schauen was
kostet so eine prothese ja eine
armprothese ist halt ein bisschen
kostenspielige weil er halt so viel
mechanik trainers also meine hat jetzt
um die 100000 euro fast 100.000 was
alles selbst bezahlt oder übernimmt das
die kasse
das hat die unfallversicherung man also
die versicherung von meinem freund das
ist ja warum bekommt sie mal eben 100
tausend euro hat ein ausbildungsplatz zu
dem zeitpunkt gehabt und ich habe ja
noch mein leben vor mir wohl überhaupt
sollte ich dann so eine prothese
bekommen die sage ich mal nur runter
hängt wenn ich noch alles so plane warum
solltest du nein sagen ja sehr anbietet
klar es gibt natürlich auch bestimmte
fälle die brauchen das die die haben
dann nicht das glück ist die
versicherung ist darum sollst du sagen
ich verzichte darauf weil es menschen
gibt die das macht ja gar keinen sinn in
dem moment man sieht ja du nutzt es und
du bist ja also eine power wie du hast
ja sowieso total beeindruckend
ich gebe jetzt nochmal ne ne dazu und
dann können wir beide sahne aufschlagen
das machen wir einfach schnell mit der
maschinen und dann ist eigentlich schon
fast der kugel dass sie ruhig und das
tier durch unsere workflows so mega
humor ich glaube müssten auf informatik
talk video jetzt einblenden körperlich
das einfach mal an
doch eigentlich schon früher ist es aber
man fragt mich mit dem nackten finger
auf leute fehlte auch das ist doch cool
[Musik]
die sonne ist schön steif geschlagen da
gar kein sand fest oder so rein gemacht
der mir schon diese geliermittel in der
creme und jetzt tue ich das rein und du
wirst das schön münchen frei also rühren
ist für dich ja gar kein thema rühren
ist ja es war dann ist ist auch feuer
herdplatte ich was ist denn so das
größte manko in der küche wurde mainz
sogar das fällt jetzt richtig schwer
außer dosen öffnen eier aufschlagen
klar also ich kriegs hin aber es ist
halt oft mit sauberer mit die schale
noch mit rein jahr ist also das richtig
sauber zu trennen
deshalb ist halt schon schwer so es
sonst ja wie gesagt so kartoffeln halt
stehlen uns sowas und ist dadurch mehr
gleich mal nicht fast futtermittel ich
mehr so diese fertiggerichte oder machst
du trotzdem noch frisches essen also ich
bin ehrlich ich bin noch jungen jahr wir
essen schon wie fahrten aber wenn mein
freund jetzt seine abnehmen phase ist
versuche ich halt schon deswegen
gesünderes machen halt wenn wir
irgendwie so zu machen dass er das mit
zu das ist also mit zureden nicht normal
mode
ich brauche halt viel länger sowohl für
die zehn minuten motto ich habe 20
minuten für es halt alles mit viel mehr
aufwand verbunden das glaube ich ihm was
mit lebensbereichen bist du denn noch so
eingeschränkt man anziehsachen an und
ausziehen kriegst du da hilft oder hast
du da auch tricks ich mache alles
eigentlich allein class strumpfhosen
sind schon schwer so das werde ich auch
oft gefragt wie straßen hosen anziehen
es dauert halt auch länger aber ich fix
hin ja aber wenn ich dann mal wie wenn
meine oma oder jan mir hilft mich sagte
sie mal eben schnell die hose also
beiden seiten ist halt schon angenehm
als es lägen direkt man dann in das
stück fisch ja auch lernt man schon wenn
jemand anders ist dann merkt man wieder
auch so schnell kann es eigentlich gehe
nicht kennst jetzt so deswegen ist es
für mich nicht schlimm aber wenn ich
dann sehe dass jemand anderes das macht
und ich sehe wie schnell es eigentlich
geht merke ich schon so
okay ist schon es ist schon anders ok
und guckst du auch bei anderen menschen
mehr auf die aber jetzt nach dem unfall
ja ich achte sehr auf linke also gerade
bei frauen es klingt jetzt komisch aber
ich gucke mir jetzt schon an wenn wir
dann so viel mit dem linken arm agieren
und so denkt schon soja ist schön
ja also klar als man noch ich bin ok
damit ich hab es auch so akzeptiert aber
ich würde lügen wenn ich sagen würde
dass ich den nicht zurückhaben möchte
bleibt ja ich bin froh einfach dass ich
noch überhaupt da sein darf und leben so
groß in den beiden ins ich habe in
meinem schienbeine platte drin also
trauben bei menschen warten war
zertrümmert waren unter mal im becken
habe ich schrauben drehen und mit dem
schienbein ist halt immer noch nicht
richtig verheilt also ich habe immer
noch probleme beim gehen ich merke das
auch zwischendurch bei der knochen nicht
perfekt bündig ist sondern so versetzen
sondern es muss halt noch operiert
werden also ich finde es schön wir offen
und damit umgeht ich finds doch wichtig
weil wenn ich mich so verstecken würde
und so nicht drüber reden würde daher
ich mich mit es muss darüber gesprochen
werde und so weil ich will halt ein
bisschen 'schon aufklärung dafür
schaffen dass es ist es nichts schlimmes
ist dass man nicht denkt oh gott der
feten arm oder oh gott komme ihre beine
dann ist doch alles gut so ich kannst
dich genauso wie ihre alten wege als
hätte ich jetzt noch mein arm oder nicht
auf jeden fall das ist halt das ding und
es ist wirklich so wenn ich dich richtig
an gucke sehe ich das drumherum ja gar
nicht so wie bei jedem anderen menschen
halt ein vollwertiger mensch mit dem man
das unterhalten kann mir du schon sagst
aber ich finde das schön vor allem wir
noch leute dich dann oder dir folgen die
vielleicht das gleiche problem haben
oder eine amputation haben die nehmen
sich wahrscheinlich auch als vorbild ist
nicht wirklich menschen die ich kenne
die mit texte schreiben und es mir sagen
dass ich ein vorbild bin ich denke mir
so war das war also ich habe nie so ich
dachte wo ich damit angefangen hat ist
interessiert sich für so was was mache
ich großartig und dann das der sohn
bekam und ich einfach mit meinem wie ich
bin mit meinem wesen ein vorbild sein
kann in anderen hält
das ist halt für mich so das völlegefühl
ich verstehe mich an ich bin ja wirklich
einfach so wie ich bin
das macht es auch am ende des tages
ausland ich und das merkt man auch das
ist authentisch
ich will jetzt einfach mal dass da rein
schießen dann kannst du das gleiche
erreichen
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir die torte gekühlt und
ich habe das nicht dass ihr euch wundert
weil ihr braucht schon viel zeit ich
habe das vorbereitet gestern am
vollkommen bis und jetzt machen wir
gleich noch den guss fertig aber du
kannst schon mal die torte lösen weiß
was mich noch interessieren würde
du hast ja wahrscheinlich im
behindertenausweis klar ja schwimmen in
ein neues werk und wie sie zum plätzen
aus der dass mich das bekomme ich nicht
also aus dem rund ich bin nicht genug
behindert so blöd es klingt also ich bin
jetzt auch dabei das zu beantragen weil
ich der meinung bin mir steht es zu ich
hab mich wenn ich aussteige müsst ja ich
hab's vorstellen ich habe keinen linken
mit dem ich die tür aufmachen kann ich
kann mich nicht richtig drehen
das bag nicht ich muss dann mit dem
linken gesunden bein mache ich die tür
auf aber auch wenn leute mega einpacken
wenn ich dann dadurch laufe mit der
prothese a für deren auto blöd auch
vermeiden auto wird ich musste mich rein
quatsch mit dem becken mit dem kaputten
wein habt dann das ganze gewicht auf dem
rechten kaputten bein auch beim
einkaufen mit einem allen den wagen zu
schieben klar ich die prothese aber fakt
dass ich kann sie noch nicht perfekt
beherrschen und es wird auch nie mein
richtiger arm sein und für mich wäre das
in meinem alter eine mega erleichterung
aber ich muss darum kämpft klar ist eine
bereicherung der alltag zumindest ja
einigermaßen einfacher zu gestalten
kraft also ich bin schockiert ich finds
heftig auf was für eine grundlage und
was wollte was du was soll denn noch an
dir weiß was ich meine es ist ja schon
wirklich eine enorme behinderungen und
da muss jetzt gegen vorgehen machst du
das gerichtlich oder wie läuft das ja
also ich habe jetzt erst mal an gefechte
ich habe 70 prozent behinderungsgrad und
das ist ja nicht genug also ich denke
mir halt ich muss jetzt beweisen dass
ich es wirklich brauche und allein
diesen schritt zu gehen dass ich mich
jetzt rechtfertigen muss dass ich jetzt
alles dahin schicken muss meine art vor
richtigen gutachten alles was geschafft
oder auch kraft und ich find's einfach
zurecht weil ich habe offensichtlich
eine änderung ich lüge nicht ich möchte
hier niemanden irgendwie hintergehen
dazu gekommen einfach so und dass ich
halt einfach jetzt wieder mich darum
kümmern muss und mir so ein stress
machen muss für mich einfach warum wird
es einem so schwer gemacht das gefühl
dass die schon wollen dass man sagt
kommen weiß das ist mit so viel arbeit
ich lasse es jetzt einfach aber viele
machen was bestimmt auch wir haben ja
keine kraft mehr neben all dem was sie
hier leisten müssen da sich noch drum zu
kümmern da sage ich ehrlich wo ich auch
nicht ja wieder alles versuchen alles
einzugehen alles da hinzuschicken und am
ende dass sie dann sagen ja nee den
kriegen sie aber nicht weil ich wollte
ja schon mal haben auf meint ihr dazu
schreibt doch mal in die kommentare eure
meinung jetzt gerade zu dem thema ich
bin schockiert gerade ich mir denke
warum macht man das einem menschen so
schwer wir haben doch also es ist doch
machbar ist es wahrscheinlich ein
stempel und fertiges nah und so muss
sich jetzt damit rum quälen als wenn es
nicht schon alles genug wer also es ist
ja echt heftig stadt wuppertal
was soll das macht doch mal was ich
verstehe es einfach nicht ich hätte auch
wirklich gern also eine vernünftige
begründung die ja auch wird es dann auch
verstehen und also ok ja ihr habt recht
aber ich glaube jeder gesunde
menschenverstand sagt jetzt gerade wenn
man sich doch so anhalt das jetzt herz
ist mit denen das kann doch nicht sein
ich hoffe dass du das durch krieg ich
hoffe es so sehr
aber so berichtet darüber so was auch
auf der miete kanal gibt es da dann auch
so updates bei ich will halt super g auf
dem laufenden gehalten werden vielleicht
auch die follower auch machst du so was
ja also ich geb schon so ein blick aus
meinem leben und für mich weiß auch
einen plan über diese ganzen bürokratie
sachen zu reden weil es halt ein
wichtiges thema so es war alles nicht
einfach wird mein führerschein auch und
das steht jetzt auch an also da will ich
auf instagram bin ich sowieso mal dass
ich das update also ihr wisst was zu tun
folgt china auf jeden fall hier auf
youtube aber auch auf instagram und du
bist ja auch auf twitter haben wir
gerade gesehen
ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt den
guss dann bin ich gespannt ob die unsere
kreation schmeckt da du hast ja das
meiste gemacht heute so der gus besteht
jetzt aus muttis also einfach ein
smoothie aufgekocht und speisestärke
science musik sein schwenk ich das und
dann sind wir eigentlich
durch so was ist denn so lieblingskuchen
wo ich mag die schwarzwälder kirschtorte
der klassiker der geht immer die
überführung auf dem schwarzwald und dann
so richtig traditionell nimmt jetzt wird
heute ich abschließend gern noch mal was
fragen nochmals zurück um zu
motorradunfall zu kommen der war wann
genau am 15
september 2009 10 okay und ich war quasi
nicht alleine du warst ja mit dem freund
auf einem motorrad und dort ist mir
gerade erzählt vor euch war dann noch
deine freundin ihr genau als heute
freundin mit ihrem vater die sich vor
uns gefahren um halt zu zweit mit dem
biss hat auch gesehen im rückspiel zum
unfallort sind dann die beiden direkt
dinge haben euch direkt erst hilfe
geboten was haben nicht gemacht weil
dort ist mit grad als die kameras man
nicht an wann ist sie finde ich es super
wenn das auch noch mal die zuschauer
hören wie verhält man sich vorbildlich
weil das war glaube ich ganz schön
vorbildliches verhalten also eine
freundin ist mega ruhig geblieben die
hat permanenten mir gesprochen damit ich
halt weil bewusstsein bleiben und trotz
dass sie gemerkt hat dass der armen halt
innerlich abgerissen war sie es mir ja
ruhig problem aber sie hat nicht gesagt
oh gott was jetzt gesagt alles gut mach
dir keine sorgen es war alles gut ich
bin bei dir deine hand gehalten ich habe
halt gesagt oh gott was ist hier
passiert ich spüre nichts als ob wir es
erst habe ich gar nichts gespürt ich
sowas ist marian sie so keine sorge
alles gut lesbar jahren ich bin bei dir
und hat die ganze zeit bei mir
gesprochen ich glaube dass es mir
wichtig dass die person ruhig bleibt
weil hätte sie mich verunsichert wer
weiß was dann gewesen wäre dass die
person die ich wach hält und die sache
mit dem helm ist ja immer eine sache
zieht mal den helm aus sieht man den
helm nicht aus bei mir wurde der hermann
gelassen weil man wie sehr offen war
eigentlich sagt man ja ist es
unterschiedlich mal was anderes helm ab
weil wenn du dich über gibt dass sie
nicht an
wir brauchen das erstickt oder beim
abziehen sagt auch andrea du kannst viel
kaputt machen
aber bei mir wurde halt gucken und bei
mir war das visier offen und haben
gesagt wir lassen ihn an weiß halten ich
tat mir weh ich habe gesagt lasst ihn
bitte an zieht ihn nicht aus und sie hat
halt dadurch dass sie in der
seniorenresidenz arbeitet hat sie immer
erste hilfe kurse gehabt und kurz davor
hatte sie auch noch ein und dadurch
wussten sie halt noch mal mehr wie sie
mit mir umzugehen hat und das finde ich
so wichtig dass man das macht weil es
hat ja wirklich was gemacht also ich
weiss nicht hätte er sehe nicht so top
reagiert ob das dann alles so gewesen
wäre
ob es nicht anders gelaufen geradelt ist
vielleicht noch mehr panik bekommen
du warst wahrscheinlich in so einer
schockstarre voller adrenalin da bist du
gesagt und wenn dann jemand noch sagen
würde was ist denn hier rein das ist ja
noch schlimmer als ich jetzt daraus mit
nehme mein letzter erste hilfe kurs ist
ich glaube zwölf jahre her seit ich
meinen führerschein gemacht hat es
schadet nie den immer mal wieder
aufzufrischen weil man kann ja selbst
immer mal wieder
ersthelfer werten aus der situation
heraus es geht ja so schnell ne und
deine freundin dass die so vorbildlich
reagiert hat das hat mir noch mal eine
innere in erinnerung gerufen dass wir
einfach auch wirklich situationsabhängig
wirklich auch wirklich ruhe bewahren
sollen dass man dann wie du schon sagst
mit dem helm was man gemacht und
grundsätzlich sind motorräder sag ich
mal ja schon auch sehr gefährlich es von
vielen mit leidenschaft würdest du im
nachhinein sagen leute fahrt kein
motorrad oder oder bist du gar nicht so
dass du es jetzt komplett in der
schublade steckt möchte niemandem was
verbieten weil ich kann schon
nachvollziehen wenn man eine
leidenschaft hat dass man das nicht
messen möchte aber ich würde heben
abraten weil du hast keine knautschzone
es kam so schnell gehen du musst nicht
mehr schuld sein das ist dass du kannst
der beste fahrer der welt sein wenn an
dem tag norte kommt dann nimmt das orte
die ich mir dann zu 50 gefallen hat 30
franken hat 200 gefahren da ist es egal
wenn das auto meint ich wegzuhauen dann
haut das auto dich weg und dann kannst
du die beste lederkombi anderen den
besten handy besten hand
das bringt uns nichts und das ist halt
einfach das was das ich einfach ein
bisschen auch ich möchte den leuten
nicht ausreden ich möchte einfach dass
sie das im hinterkopf behalten hey guck
mal dass ein 20 jährige mädchen verloren
ihr becken ist kaputt die bayern ist
kaputt und die sind 70 gefahren da war
70 die haben mit meiner noch gequatscht
auf motorrad weil es muss nicht die
geschwindigkeit sein das ist die leute
dinge immer ja ich habe leider kommen
wir an ich bin geschützt auf motorrad
nähe das schützt deine haut aber das
schützt dich nicht vorwand verlust ich
habe auch eine motorradjacke angehabt
mit protektoren an der abens trotzdem
abgerissen das sind einfach so kräfte
lieder entgegenwirken und vielen ist das
nicht bewusst einfach dass die leute
sich besser einschätzen und wissen okay
das kann passieren aber die meisten
motorradfahrer wissen was passt mein
freund ist auch er hat auch gesagt er
war sich dem risiko durchaus bewusst und
ich denke aber sonst setzt man sich auch
nicht richtig ganz wichtig ist natürlich
die vorsicht aber du weißt halt vorher
nie was passiert aber schön dass du
trotzdem so damit umgeht und das zeigt
uns heute auch gattin dieser kimi
zufolge leute habt immer hoffnung wird
immer positiv eingestellt ich glaube
dass bewegt auch im kopf ganz ganz viel
wir schließen jetzt die folge mit einem
leckeren stück kuchen aber schon mit
einem schönen täter ist
[Musik]
wir übernehmen jetzt ein bisschen hart
weil die da immer hier
aber wir uns gedacht nee heute probieren
wir mal ab heute keinen job mehr caravan
man spricht nicht mit vollen text aber
jetzt also so schnell wieder weg netz
der db sowie ausgedacht der boden ist
projekt habt ihr es echt gut vor allem
der boden ist knackig und da oben in
belgrad das ried und so ein bisschen
nachmacher projekt das heißt dass ich
halt im sommer perfekt weil es so
fruchtig ist genau also was sagen wir
das auf jeden fall nach der ja definitiv
gehört nicht unbedingt nachmachen und
ansonsten möchte ich mich bei jedem mal
bedanken dass sie heute mein gast war s
check wie gesagt primas kanäle ab die
werde ich euch hier unten direkt als
erstes in die video beschreibung
verlinken und dann würde ich mal sagen
dass diesmal hieß kitchen machen wir so
[Musik]